З якими проблемами можуть зіткнутися громадські активісти в Україні,
Дмитро Шерембей знає на власному досвіді.
Він очолює "Всеукраїнську мережу людей, що живуть з ВІЛ/СНІДом".
Завдяки йому та його команді вдалося зламати низку корупційних схем із державних закупівель ліків.
Однак наприкінці минулого року в організації пройшли обшуки -
активістів звинуватили у розкраданні грантів.
Самі активісти заявляють про помсту за їхню антикорупційну діяльність.
Такого сценарію тепер бояться й інші громадські активісти,
які займаються антикорупційною боротьбою в Україні.
Обов'язок заповнювати електронні декларації вони розцінюють не інакше як важіль тиску на них.
Так само це розцінили й партнери України в ЄС та США.
І хоча президент Порошенко неодноразово обіцяв їм скасувати цю норму - віз і досі там.
Чим це загрожує Україні?
По-перше, це суттєві іміджеві втрати.
Кредит довіри до української влади на європейській арені і так помітно тане.
Варто очікувати нової критики з Брюсселя,
ймовірно, дебатів і резолюції з цього питання в Європарламенті,
а також критики у звіті доповідачів Європарламенту щодо України,
який обговорюватиметься вже у червні.
Друг України у Європарламенті Пятрас Ауштрявічюс назвав провальне голосування
у Верховній Раді цього тижня поганим подарунком до Великодня.
Ми сподіваємося, що прогресивні сили у Верховній Раді не гратимуть в ігри,
а поглянуть на майбутнє України серйозно.
Бо вимоги європейських інституцій залишатимуться незмінними.
Зараз м'яч на боці Верховної Ради.
І я закликаю депутатів взяти це до уваги і зробити висновки.
За критичними заявами можуть послідувати і більш болючі для України кроки,
приміром, згортання фінансової допомоги.
Це не те, що ЄС хоче робити.
Але я припускаю, що якщо ця ситуація затягуватиметься,
то вірогідно, що щось подібне трапиться.
Адже ЄС не може заплющувати на це очі.
Це було би дуже хибно, бо дало би дуже поганий сигнал.
Україна чує меседж ЄС, але не дослухається до нього, вони глухі…
Проведення необхідних реформ і боротьба з корупцією були також частиною домовленості з ЄС
при введенні безвізового режиму для українців.
Про цей важіль в руках Брюсселя українській владі теж радять не забувати.
Однак розмови про можливе обмеження "безвізу" в Брюсселі вважають передчасними.
ЄС чекає результатів. ЄС терплячий.
А от наскільки терпляча Україна у своїй інтеграції в Євросоюз -
цю відповідь вже має дати Київ.
Якою буде ця відповідь, європарламентарі цими днями з'ясовують у Києві.
Делегація комітету закордонних справ Європарламенту
на зустрічах з президентом Порошенком, прем’єром Гройсманом,
а також з представниками громадянського суспільства, перевіряє втілення реформ у країні.
Тож, українській владі доведеться ще не раз пояснювати,
чому е-декларування для активістів досі не скасоване.